in the springtime it's everything has to
do with weather and conditions it once
it dries up and we're out of the heavy
frost so let's say the middle of april
we'll start planting potatoes and it
takes four to six weeks to plant the
crops after that if it's dry we're into
irrigation to keep the crops healthy
and in the summer time we keep the
program going and then we start harvest
usually the first of august as soon as
the potatoes are mature enough after two
weeks then we start harvesting and we go
right to the middle of october and then
we're hopefully we're done we're we're
down to regular hours in the winter time
we do maintenance and we check all the
equipment over for the following year
and it never seems
like we have a data we have nothing to
do there's always something we have lots
of equipment to check out so before
we're done it's spring again
[Music]